here with reaction its former White
House press secretary Sean Spicer he's
actually in the meeting when Comey did
brief then president-elect Trump about
the dossier and former Deputy Assistant
the president from Fox News national
security strategist dr. Sebastian worker
all right Sean you were in the room you
don't see it the same way you don't
recall it the same way no I think the
account that director Comey has in his
book is at best misleading so let me lay
it out for you on January 11th the four
intelligence Chiefs came up to Trump
Tower
they were about to issue a report on
their findings of Russian involvement in
the election and wanted us to be aware
of what that report was gonna be we sat
down had that report given to us at
which time there was a series of
questions that were asked by Reince
Priebus general Flynn Tom Bossert the
Homeland Security Advisor and vice
president Mike Pence after the
discussion ended and again a key point
in that is that there was a lot of
questions back and forth which director
Comey suggests didn't occur but I just
named four of those people that
definitely asked questions then at that
point director Comey said to the
president-elect may I see you privately
in the back of the room we got up the
rest of us exited the room the secure
room that we had received the briefing
in and went outside at that time as you
may recall there was a little bit of
distrust among some of the political
appointees director clapper and director
Brennan so we ran by the statement that
we're going to issue to make sure that
it was in accord with the classified
nature of the briefing and that they
weren't going to differ in terms of
their account of the meeting that we had
just had and Comey goes on in his book
to talk about how it became a PR session
that's not true that's not how it went
down and again as I noted a lot of
people did that further has Comey
himself Tesla says in his in his
reporting here he believed reefed the
president on some of these salacious and
unproven allegations CNN went on to
report on a report falsely that he'd
been given a two-page report that report
wasn't actually even done at the time
that we were briefed
so both director Comey's account of it
is misleading and CNN's reporting of
that meeting are false all right let me
go to dr. Gorka so you know the big the
big issue for the media for over a year
has been all Russia
influence in the election and james
comey knew before the election hillary
paid a foreign national
Kristopher steals through perkins coolly
through fusion gps and they paid for
russian lies to manipulate the american
people and then they used it to get a
FISA warrant and then he exonerated
Hillary after Peter struck he
interviewed er but they wrote the
exoneration months earlier and I'm
trying to think what you can't make this
irony up when you think about it it's
not just ironic so you're absolutely
right you look at the last 15 months
what do we know we have no evidence of
Russian collusion between the president
and his campaign but we know for certain
that James Comey is a liar we know that
James Comey leaks to the media we know
the fact that he tries to get his body
Robert Muller to become the special
prosecutor investigating the president
who he didn't want to win the election
his wife didn't didn't want Trump to win
nor did Comey these are the facts of the
case he has done more single-handedly to
damage the FBI than J Edgar Hoover has
done and if you look at the fact that in
his interview yesterday he's propagating
the narrative of the the president
potentially being a pawn of the Russians
what is he doing with zero evidence he's
actually assisting in a Russian Zhun
information operation that's what James
Comey is doing and he presented that
phony information to a court to spy on
an American Sean well I think look like
it's not just misleading what he's
saying now is frankly irresponsible to
go out there and profess loyalty and
concern for these institutions and then
openly speculate with no evidence is
highly irresponsible now he's free to do
it it's a free country you can do it but
you can't go around and talk about the
the loyalty that you have to the
institutions to this country and openly
speculate about things of that nature
and not and not wonder and not and not
have the opposite effect there's a
reason I think that the directors book
and his account and his appearance are
getting pan and that's because I think
he's it's become about him and about his
image and his
to sell books and not the truth last
word dr. Guerra I'll just tell you what
I received recently a text from an FBI
agent the senior one this person told me
for the first time in her life she is
ashamed to work for the FBI and that she
said his thanks to James Comey that's
what he has done in the name of his ego
and his book well we got to remember
it's not the rank and file as a matter
of fact
99.9% do a great job protecting us every
day